so
[Music]
in
too much muscle
well you got to do it though
yeah do you see
[Music]
do we
going around
did you feel yourself snaking around go
to the next okay
oh you're going around
[Music]
this is
right there whatever's in the way
same thing whatever is in the way
trying to go around is
because you can't let it go through you
you're trying to take
resistance off externally
that's not cooking full
let's go
here
so his center is my conditioning
is my stressor that creates the
adaptation
it gives me the two options
you could do big man aikido
this is not aikido but you try to push
through it
or you internalize it and his resistance
goes through me okay so if you look
we do this drill and he's pushing
that energy is going through me down to
the ground path do you see okay you guys
going through me well it's no different
then if i was pushing him
this energy would go to the ground pop
well it's no different when i'm coming
through
his energy's going through me
okay so
you don't want to go around the center
because that's not the drill you you
drive the center because that's the best
stressor which causes the best
adaptation you don't go around it
you see
so the same thing as you get there don't
go around it
try to keep trying to make your center
move keep moving forward
keeps going that way
forward
got it don't go around
[Music]
all right
so it's cookie hole it's like taiso it's
kokuho when i do the throat eiffel taiso
is the ten con coqui horizon throw
cocy hole is not big man aikido it's not
overpowering kokyu hall is his energy
can pass through me
did that
yes i would i rebounded but prior to
that is passing through me got it so i
did the same stressor
and then i get to the same crossroads
will i just push on it or i just let it
pass through me and the ground energy
does the rest okay so
i'm gonna do my tank on i'm gonna stay
in the back and there it is right there
so in the same way
that you feel for his center you have to
feel for his center do not go around it
[Music]
boom
it'll look like i'm pushing through his
elbow i'm not pushing through his elbow
okay
but
if my hand
takes that elbow out of his midsection
then i did not push into his center okay
[Music]
and again if you watch
i'm not going to accelerate him
backwards into this stepping down thing
i want his center to move
his center moves
make his center move
and it's the same
relaxed hands
last half
in intent on
unlocking me
he has to be the one that comes to you
okay
how does that work out there not very
much
okay so what is hard
has to be able to be soft and what is
soft has to be able to be harmed what
does that means what is technicon has to
be able to enter and what does it mean
has to be able to yield okay
so i'm not doing ed me again on now
there is a yield right he's pushing
there's a yield
you see and then in the yield is the
ticking
the first heels not going here
there's a yield
very soft
then for the other one you're going to
see he's going that way i'm just
accelerating the way he's going that was
not what we did in the 80 meter so we're
going around he's going that way
so a little
[Music]
oh
bye